If you put
your Tik Tok's down
you'll have a chance
to see some people dancing
in real life.
It's gonna be great.
Oh, we have some
weird-ass traditions
at this school.
Get down the floor, do it
Come on
and get down the floor, go
I grab my ankle
and pull it up
And do that thing
where I move my butt
I got the juice,
don't use it up
I say woo there it is,
then loosen my tux
And then I shimmy, shimmy,
shimmy, shimmy to the left
Shimmy, shimmy, shimmy,
shimmy to the right
Gimme, gimme, gimme,
everything that you got
Dance off...
do the damn thing right
She got loose elbows
and a big ol' neck
I like a big boned girl
who could work up a sweat
I rock shelltoes
and a turtleneck
She just wanna talk,
I said, I ain't TED
(Dance off)
Hater with the macarena
I can roger ride
but in my office space
If you watch my pace
looks like
I'm concentrated
Or constipated
when I walk this way
I challenge you
to a dance off
Hands off, no trash talk,
no back walk
On the black top
just me, you, that's all
No cat calls,
no tag teams, no mascots
Right now, dance off
(Dance off)
Get down the floor
Get down the,
get down the floor, go
Get down the floor, do it
Come on
and get down the floor
Rewind!
Go, go, go, go
(Dance off)
I sneak up behind you
like a panther
Who ordered
the private dancer?
Jump on the tablecloth,
fake a fall
Pretend to break my arm
then I'm breaking you off
Blat! Please don't tell
my baby he's mine
I wanna dance all night
'til the break of dawn
Wanna sweat, sweat, sweat
'til your make-up's gone
Baby girl, you looking
like a champion
Hey you, you bad
get up out of your chair
Paid twenty bucks
to get up in this club
put your cellphone down
you square
I be going in,
I can't help it
I got bruises
on my pelvis
Ladies, fellas
I challenge you
to a dance off
Hands off, no trash talk,
no back walk
On the black top
just me, you, that's all
No cat calls,
no tag teams, no mascots
Right now, dance off
(Dance off)
Get down the floor
Get down the,
get down the floor, go
Get down the floor, do it
Come on
and get down the floor
Rewind!
Go, go, go, go
(Dance off)
Rewind!